almighty father creator and sustainer of
us all you have brought us safely to
this day
give us minds to thank you for all of
your providential mercies Lord Jesus
Christ only Son of the Father and savior
of the world you have shed upon us the
light of your Antonio brace give us
hearts to love you in return Holy Spirit
advocate and guide you have made us to
be fit vessels for your glory give us
wills to walk and step with you and to
bring forth your fruits most glorious
and Blessed Trinity ever one God by the
blood of the eternal covenant you have
adopted us as children into your divine
family we ask now that you so guide our
minds so fill our imaginations so
control our wills
that we may be wholly yours utterly
dedicated to you and then use us we pray
as you will and always to your glory and
the welfare of your people this we ask
with boldness on the merits of Jesus
Christ our Savior amen please turn and
face the flag with me
I pledge allegiance to the flag
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning to all and welcome to the
Fall Convocation a special thanks to our
organist
dr. Derek Stav to the Hillsdale College
Chamber Choir under the direction of
Professor James Holloman and Debbie
Weiss and to route Reverend Adam Rick
for the invocation and benediction
distinguished members of the platform
party today are dr. Larry Arne president
dr. Michael Ward our speaker dr. mark
altough dean of faculty dr. Matthew
young Dean of Natural Sciences dr.
Stephen Smith Dean of humanities dr.
Paul Marino Dean of the social sciences
dr. RJ post reto Graduate Dean and
Reverend Adam rec college chaplain now
for the scholarships
all right the all-school grade point
average for spring 2019 three point
three nine nine this is the same every
time they all women's average so if
member three point three nine nine all
women's average three point four eight
six the all men's average three point
three one seven with a GPA of 3.5 to
zero the sorority scholarship goes to Pi
Beta Phi what a representative please
come forward
with a GPA of 3.30 to the fraternity
scholarship goes to al-fatah Omega the
representation for
Larry P Arnn is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University of
graduating with highest distinction
he received his MA and his PhD in
government from the Claremont Graduate
School he also studied in England first
as a research student in international
history at the London School of
Economics and then in modern history at
Oxford University well in England he
also served as director for a research
for the Sir Martin for the late Sir
Martin Gilbert the official biographer
Winston Churchill who returned to the
United States to become editor for
public research syndicated and he served
as president of the Claremont Institute
and education research institution based
in Southern California while a Claremont
he was the founding chairman of the
California Civil Rights initiative which
was passed by California voters in 1996
and prohibited racial preference and
state hiring contracting and emissions
dr. Arnn is on the board of directors at
the Heritage Foundation the Henry
Salvatori Center for Claremont McKenna
College the intercollegiate Studies
Institute and the Claremont Institute he
served on the US Army War College Board
of Visitors for two years for which he
earned the Department of Army's
outstanding civilian service medal in
2015 dr. Arum received the Bradley prize
from the Lynde and Harry Bradley
Foundation he is a member of the
American Political Science Association
the international Churchill Society the
Mount Pelerin Society the Philadelphia
society and the philanthropy Roundtable
published widely and national newspapers
magazines and periodicals on issues of
Public Policy history and political
theory is the author of three books
Liberty and learning the evolution of
American education
the founders key the deveined and
national connection between the
Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it and
Churchill's trial Winston Churchill and
the salvation of free government dr.
Arnn and his wife Penelope have four
children
Katie Henry Alice and Tony please join
me in welcoming dr. Larry our
[Applause]
good morning can you hear in the balcony
it works now okay welcome this building
was built with this service in mind we
hope it works for it
I see the Academy has showed up in force
and their behavior was okay I thought
coming in good job is done construct
here it's supposed to be here I was
looking for him oh he's up there what
are you doing up there so he can hear
yeah there was a problem
Duncan strike designed this building and
we should thank him for that
I see that several senior people in the
college administration are sitting on
the dangerous precarious front row there
and if one of them falls off there'll be
a job opening are you curious who
actually built this building they sit
right there would you stand up place
[Applause]
this building is produced by the love of
millions of people and that includes
those people I visited this building
many more times than I had time to do in
many times more times than I've ever
builded another building because it's
wondrous to watch it unfold and I know
is Larry Weekend here no he couldn't
come tell him I said this I said it
before this weekend construction company
was the general contractor on this and
about halfway through they told mr.
peewee that they were going to lose
about a million bucks on this I think it
was more than that why because nobody's
built anything like this forever
so there's hard to estimate what it
would cost what it would take and then
they told us a great thing they told us
not they weren't going to tell these
people that because they were trying to
build this building perfect and they
didn't want them to stop doing that so
the names of all of these people are
going to go on a plaque that's going to
be put up in here and preserved to thank
them for their service it's spectacular
to watch thank you for showing me what
you did
we held this service for something north
of 160 years in the college baptist
church that's down the street it was
built in a partnership between the
college and the town started in the
1850s over the years things changed the
college never owned that church but it
was its home and over the years things
changed the college has a glorious
history but like all long histories it
has its modulations and they altered the
structure so that it would seat fewer
people and they had more space for other
kinds of activities in the back and the
college grew and so we thought we have
to do something about 20 years ago we
made a plan for the campus and I I was
the one who said we have to have a
chapel I didn't know what I was saying I
knew enough to know that it would be
difficult cost a lot of money not yield
much revenue that kind of thing right
there's so many things around here like
that and I didn't know where it should
be and you know back then it could not
have been where it's it's right here I
noticed that the chapel places me in a
reverie when I come in here because one
forgets life is so busy one forgets the
things that have happened and here this
is a reminder of things that had to
happen for this chapel to be here and
when we began we didn't know what those
things were this back of the campus we
had to remove an obstacle our largest
classroom building and it has been
described by great architects as ugly
[Laughter]
and these guys over here they had their
offices in it and they were so happy to
be in there you know and it there was a
there was a large crowd of faculty
gathered when we started tearing it down
there was a great jumper and it it's a
big old brick building we're inside and
out as was the style here for a while
and they and the chopper bit into it and
they were loud cheers and then I ran up
to the Foreman I said wait that's the
wrong building the Student Union is here
now and it this fits with that duncan
has made it so eventually something's
gonna happen over there I don't know
what and in God's good time but what's
over there is gonna fit with this and
the center of the campus is an integrity
now we're going to redo the back of
central hall God giving us the dough and
it's gonna look like the front of
central hall and it's going to match
with this back here and David Whelan
will have a quarrel about the window
with Duncan strike and whether it should
match the window in the front of the
central hall or where the match that
would window right up there so far the
betting is Duncan's gonna win he won the
last one and David sallied forth many
times so you see this is a development
development toward what the college has
been trying to become fully itself since
the beginning intensely in recent years
why everywhere around us there's a
crisis there's decay the simmering
conflict or actual conflict everywhere
and the conflict concerns every
fundamental thing what does family mean
what does God mean the people who love
God
are they committing some injury against
their neighbors which is a public claim
often made now and so in a time like
that CS Lewis writes things come to a
point and there's not as much neutral
ground as there used to be and so we are
responding to that and we're all here
today to thank God that this happened
because we who were actually in charge
of making it happen
we didn't know until the last step what
it would take most plans are made
through principle and hope and there's
an element of practical judgment
required but when you look at a thing
like this you see that that's not such a
big element so much has to happen that
you can't just make happen we should
remember to be grateful for that you
students are going to carry the college
into the future that's actually your job
to learn what it has to teach understand
that you've come to it at a time that's
very different here than anywhere else
because the things that we were made to
teach or what we seek to teach and not
many people who learn that you are the
point think about this building
think about the relationship it
represents between faith and learning
between faith and freedom think about
that and for the rest of your life
teach others about it because they don't
get the chance to learn
I always make a hash of this so I'm
gonna do it again it's not the Emily dot
tree award
it's the Emily Daugherty award does
anybody know if that's right
and the woman who gave us anonymously is
a particular friend of mine and her name
is Susan McNair and I always say on that
name and I always mispronounced the name
of her mother it's crazy but we are
grateful to her because she thought this
up and it maybe is one of them it's one
of the best it's not maybe it's one of
the best awards we give why because it's
given in the fall to a junior faculty
member and to in the spring to a senior
one for being an excellent teacher and
that is the point around here isn't it
and well there's so many of them sitting
over there you know if you stay here
long enough you're gonna win it okay or
else somebody's gonna kill you we're
gonna sit you up there on that front row
up there this year's winner is a
fulfillment of a prediction I made the
prediction I made when we hired a
certain faculty member and I said if we
hired that guy the first thing that's
gonna happen is the classes are all
gonna swell up and we're gonna have to
hire more this is the lore
he's a fine young man he's a superb
scholar he's an excellent colleague to
the people in the German Department yeah
[ __ ] was the one we hired and I could
just see you know the great Everhard guy
or was the chairman of that department
then and it's just grown Steven Dallman
has been here since 2013 he got a BA in
pre Seminary studies in 2001 oh I didn't
know this he you should all study with
him he has a bachelor's degree in
tourism and travel as well as German
get that got to take you to Germany MA
and PhD in German studies he spent time
in Germany and Poland where he met his
wife his German and polish are fluent he
knows a little Spanish she says he
learned see that's the way I put it
he learned ancient Greek also Biblical
Hebrew and Latin well it pre seminary
I'd like to say that the past tense
I learned Greek till I remember any not
enough Stefan Norman is a blessing to
the college and we are grateful to have
him please come forward with Freddy
Annika
[Applause]
hey guys I forgot about the money
now Minh gets money and the department
gets money and I think that that's I
think that's black stocks idea so that
they wouldn't quarrel
[Applause]
was anybody else particularly struck by
the grade point averages this year do
you realize that the academic standards
of the girls and the boys at Hillsdale
College are the same did you realize
that they they we have as many
applicants are now a few more lately
from boys than from girls and nobody
gets that
and yet the boys what are you doing cuz
you're not dumb it's got to be bad
character
straighten up also here's the way I'm
not gonna come in on whether the
scholarship winner among the
fraternities had a higher or lower grade
point average than the men's average
which is of course notoriously lower
than the women's average so if we
compared those numbers we might think
the Greeks boys ought to study more I'm
just saying you're all doing fine and we
probably won't throw you out of here
probably okay
we don't pay Michael Ward enough money
for us to call him our own but if
somebody will please work out a deal
with him than we will
I'm tired of hinting about it he is a
remarkable man he's got long experience
as a chaplain chaplain and a professor
in both Oxford and Cambridge he's a
fellow at Houston Baptist and I don't
know what he does there but whatever
that is he should do it here there are
two distinctive things about him one is
I've called him before the best student
of CS Lewis and he is that I think that
more now than I did then his book planet
Narnia is tremendous and what he did was
just take seriously what the book meant
which is what lit professors do when
they are any good and it's a revelation
to read it and it makes you marvel at a
thing that you may already have loved
because you see that it is a work of art
on a higher level than you realized
what happened to me he's the second
thing is he's got this wicked wit he's
been here twice before to give important
speeches once commencement and and in
this commencement speech he gave one of
the finest commencement speeches any of
us has ever heard but it began with
about five minutes of making fun of the
name of the college and then you know
because it is a weird name isn't it you
ever heard anything else named Hillsdale
there's only one place I know of and it
was directly copied after us down in
Oklahoma and why because when do you are
you gonna do it again I'm gonna remind
he said you know is it a Dale belonging
to a hill you know it's kind of silly
and then he
deemed himself by associating the name
with an imaginary world he made up as a
kill as a kid called tor or something
tor Dale writes which is it's a synonym
for Hillsdale so that's by the way
that's the kind of thing Lewis and
Tolkien did when they were kids and when
they were grown right they made up these
fantasy worlds and they name stuff in
them so this is another third really
weird guy we asked him to speak at the
groundbreaking of this Chapel and that
was just right to do because of what he
is what he represents in the world so
much like what we try to represent and
now we've asked him to speak at our
first convocation also extremely
important appropriate Michael Ward
[Applause]
good morning everybody thank you for
having me back yes I was at the
groundbreaking two and a half years ago
and it's a huge privilege now to see
this building complete and fully
splendid I congratulate you president on
and indeed everybody concerned builders
architects college in general in
bringing this massive project to a
successful conclusion last time I was
here I seem to recall I attempted a
little spirited wordplay not about the
Hillsdale on my most recent visit but on
dr. Ahn's academic expertise in
Churchill and on this church on a hill
and here it is but of course what we
find ourselves within today is not
strictly a church it is a chapel and so
I want to begin my remarks by asking why
this building has been called Christ
Chapel well there's several answers to
that question it's been called Christ
Chapel partly to reflect the devout
Christian faith of the principal
benefactors Jack and Joe Babbitt it's
partly Christ's Chapel because its
architecture gives homage to that Church
in Philadelphia where America's founding
fathers worshiped during the Continental
Congress and I'll be coming back to that
Church in Philly later on for now I just
want to note that that church was and is
called Christ's Church
this is Christ's chapel so what is the
distinguishing feature of a chapel what
is the etymology of the word chapel and
to answer those questions I invite you
to accompany me in imagination back in
time to fourth century Europe it's the
early fourth century and the Emperor
Constantine is presiding over the Roman
Empire we find ourselves in a part of
Europe somewhat to the east and somewhat
to the south in what would today be
called Hungary
we're in a province called Pannonia and
we enter the house of a soldier whose
wife has just given birth to a baby boy
a mother and the father give their son
the name Martin from Martinus diminutive
of Martius pertaining to Mars a highly
appropriate name not only because the
boy's father is in the Roman army but
because Martin himself will soon grow up
and enter upon a military career himself
he becomes an officer and is assigned to
duty in Gaul modern-day France on
garrison duty at a meal one winter's day
as he rides through the city gates on
his horse Martin does something that is
so unexpected so memorable so striking
that it's been recounted in literature
and represented in art ever since on
that cold day this young Tribune dressed
in the regalia of his unit gleaming
armor ridged helmet large white cloak
lined with lamb's wool he sees a poor
man begging by the roadside a man whose
clothes are so raggedy he's hardly
covered at all the beggar is shaking
with the cold and Martin on an impulse
jumps from his horse command two of his
retinue to dis smelt with him takes off
his large white cloak orders his two men
to hold it out taut between them and
then with one quick stroke of his sword
he slashes the garment in two he then
hands one half to the beggar pulls the
remaining half round his own shoulders
remounts and rides on his way that night
he dreams he dreams and sees Christ in
heaven saying to the Angels Martin
clothed me with his robe and after
Martin's death many years later he died
in the year 397 the part of the cloak
that he kept was preserved in his honor
in an oratory of the abbey at tour in
middle of France 150 miles southwest of
Paris and what does all this have to do
with the word Chapel let us consult the
dictionary which tells us that the word
Chapel derives from the cappella or
cloak of st. Martin preserved by the
Frankish Kings as a sacred relic a term
Chapel the dictionary says was applied
to the sanctuary in which this cloak was
preserved under the care of its Catalani
or chaplains and thence generally to a
sanctuary containing holy relics and
finally to any building for orisons or
worship not being a regular church thus
says the oxford english dictionary and
if oxford says so it must be true
so this soldier this Caped Crusader
Martin is now known to the world as
Saint Martin of Tor tio urs the S is
silent but if you are a Chilean you
would say Tours Churchill scorm those
English travelers who insisted on saying
they'd visited Marseilles
Leon and PE no he said he visited
Marseilles Lyons and Paris foreign names
were made for Englishmen not Englishmen
for foreign names and I'm sure Churchill
would have called this Roman soldier st.
Martin of Tours patron saint of package
holidays in fact st. Martin is the
patron saint of among other things the
US Army's quartermaster regiment and so
popular was Martin for many centuries
after his death that Martin Luther the
great reformer was named after him and
baptized on his feast day November the
11th we marked it in the church calendar
on Monday this week and this whole
season of the year is known in some
places as Martin muss you have Christmas
you have candle miss you have Michaelmas
you also have mater
thus the University of st. Andrews in
Scotland where I got my PhD calls this
semester Martinmas in their academic
calendar there's an old proverb that
runs his Martinmas must come as it does
to every hog in other words all must die
because November was the great
slaughtering time of the anglo-saxons
when fodder was all used up an ox and
sheep and hogs were killed and salted
for the winter so we've already found
two links between ourselves here today
in Christ's Chapel and Martin of Tours
this building is called a chapel because
of his bisected cappella and this time
of year is Martinmas because of his
November feast day can we find a third
link with some Martin pleasingly we can
this third link is via that building in
Philadelphia that I mentioned earlier
for Christ Church in Philly on which
this building is modeled was itself
modeled on a famous church in central
London called st. martin-in-the-fields
as the name in the fields would imply
that church originally stood out in the
countryside but the city gradually
surrounded it and Sint Maarten in the
fields is now right in the heart of a
British capital next to Trafalgar Square
and the National Gallery it's one of the
best-known churches in England and the
interior of this building owes an
unmistakable debt to that church the
Corinthian columns the barrel ceiling
the shape of the windows especially the
tripartite window behind me Christ's
Chapel Hillsdale is the architectural
grandchild of st. martin-in-the-fields
so we have a three-fold link to Martin
of Tours the etymological link the
calendrical link the architectural link
and a scripture reminds us a three-fold
cord is not easily broken so let's think
more deeply about Martin and his
startling act of generosity that has no
being forgotten how foolish of him we
might say if we were in a skeptical or a
cynical mood how foolish of him to start
chopping up his own clothes like that
wouldn't it have made much better sense
to give the beggar money with which he
could have bought himself a complete a
complete new cloak how impulsive how
impractical how non universalize abour
for after all what about the next beggar
that he meets will that beggar get a
quarter of the cloak and the next beggar
1/8 where will it all end Jesus says in
the Gospels whoever has two cloaks let
him share with him who has none he said
nothing about slicing your cloaks in
half
well these sorts of questions betray a
rather pedantic mindset and they
overlook the crucial dream that gives us
the context for the whole interaction in
the dream Christ says Martin clothed me
with his robe so the beggar turns out to
be a rather important character in this
memorable incident unfolding by the
gates of a Mian or as Churchill would
say I ends it would seem it's not so
much Martin but the Shivering wretch by
the side of the road whose the holy hero
of the story well it should we imitate
the beggar should we dress ourselves and
ranks give away all our advantages move
to France England maybe France never
but again these questions betray a
small-minded focus on dragging some
policy proposal out of this memorable
encounter Martin and the beggar met in
the Roman Empire of the fourth century
where interaction is not a template for
social services or the charitable sector
in a modern Western democracy rather I
think it's a perennial II telling moral
and spiritual story about a sword and
cloak let's approach this story
poetically symbolically Martin bore a
sword he had power he had strength he
wielded military might he enforced the
Pax Romana no doubt he was a strong man
physically who could actually do harm
with that weapon he had a sword but he
also had a cloak let us picture it as a
warm soft thick richly embroidered
garment so very different from the
tattered rags of the beggar the poor
man's need was on display for all to see
but Martin underneath his garments was
just another man like him what was the
difference between the two I'm put in
mind of Shakespeare's King Lear who
tells us through tattered clothes great
vices do appear robes and furred gowns
hide all clothing masks clothing hides
without clothing we're ashamed and naked
like Adam and Eve after the fall
everyone must have clothes they're a
symbol of our human frailty of our need
and perhaps more especially for those
who pride themselves on their power
clothes are needed to preserve that
fragile pretence of invulnerability for
which of us is never in need we here
today don't lack clothes on our backs
God but do we lack nothing how many of
us are privately struggling with all
sorts of difficulties and deficiencies
this very morning our relationships are
going awry our health is giving us pause
for thought we're worried about our
exams where are we going in life and why
but even if we're wholly secure in our
relationships even if we're uh turley
confident about our abilities even if
we've won first prize in all the
competitions we've ever entered or ever
will enter so what our Martinmas must
come as it does to every Hagen so this
is where we would do well I think to
consider the sword and the cloak
together where they meet think of that
sharp sword and that stylish cloak and
now see the one slicing the other in
half see the frayed edge where the sword
went through but the sword went through
out of generosity nothing worse out of
largeness of heart
Martin's act may have been impulsive but
the impulse was one of magnanimity not
one of hatred or despair or violence his
act was a recognition that all human
beings have to shiver when they're cold
so let us at least stand by one another
compassionately now giving now receiving
now feeling our power now knowing our
weakness it's curious when you think
about it really isn't it that a chapel
should be a place for a torn cape the
fragment of cloth how would it be though
if if the cloak was still intact
testimony only to Martin's talent for
self-preservation
that would not have been worth housing
in a place of honor so there's nothing
very special about looking out for
number one but a cloak rent asunder
that's another thing altogether bisected
for all the right reasons
that's a cape of good hope it points us
to other severance is doesn't it more
profound eternal severance is even think
of the curtain of the temple torn in two
think of Christ's side pierced with the
spear think of the rock in the desert
gushing forth water when Moses struck it
with the rod the gash admits the grace
it's the crack where the light gets in
as Leonard Cohen almost said and we all
have swords and cloaks of various kinds
we have powers we have needs we have
abilities we have deficiencies so this
Martin must in this marvelous Marshall
Chapel I propose that we both celebrate
the sword and acknowledge a cloak and
above all hallow the intersection of the
two we're in weakness strength is made
perfect thank you
[Applause]
please stand for the benediction
and now by the grace of Almighty God may
you be filled with the knowledge of his
will and all wisdom and understanding so
as to walk in a manner worthy of the
Lord fully pleasing to him and bearing
fruit and every good work and may you be
strengthened with all power according to
his glorious might for all endurance and
patience with joy giving thanks to him
in all things and the blessing of God
Almighty the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit be amongst you and remain with
you always
amen
[Music]
[Applause]
you